and it's interesting too they don't
really have a firm grasp on female
nature and I used to I used to find this
a little offensive so I kind of
understand like when you first hear it
it sounds trigger triggering but it's
like women we are so easy to to
propagate like they Elites have known
this for over a hundred years women if
you just tell us things like get in our
ear you can literally convince us of
goddamn anything I mean look it we we
could be anything for because of
feminism feminism said women you can do
whatever you want and a lot of us just
decided to go be that that was
the best outcome like think of this this
is how easy to maneuver and manipulate
so what
and and it and it shows in the data like
women are much more likely to get
divorced when their friends get divorced
there's a reason that we follow fashion
trends right